like I gotta see if I can change my
flight legit our whole goal with these
events Yemen reckless village Empire is
to make it accessible until they deal
with people and do creative through your
community I love putting out events and
bring good people together what is that
welcome everybody to the modeling master
show where I sit down with successful
entrepreneurs that I want to pick their
brain and learn from I've got a special
guest with me here Casey Adams this man
is a young entrepreneur success story
he's got successful podcasts that I was
interviewed on rise of the young I am
number 86 go check out that episode it
was fire it was tons of fun
he's got a Instagram account build your
empire with 1.5 million followers with
an M there and he's putting on his own
events he's meeting tons of people and I
wanted to bring him on to pick his brain
Casey
welcome cool now can you take me on a
quick little tour or show me something
personal since we got you on your phone
here yeah absolutely so me in terms of
just the story or what know like
something something in your cuz this is
a chance against me something in your
spot yeah something personal
what is that and catch it yeah way to
just practice your focus and it's a good
thing I do whatever I'm called sometimes
I just pop it up and down and remain
focused now how long did it take you to
get that you know nailed it on the first
try there I got the beach in Outer Banks
North Carolina and I just keep it on my
desk and whatever I'm feeling I'm antsy
or whatever I can grab that and just pop
it up and down it's got a kendama for
everyone wondering I loved it and you
got a whiteboard behind you there yeah
so you got the whiteboard and then I
know something that you were intrigued
with was these shoes the Germans so my
buddy Johnny is a designer and I'm he
sent me a couple pairs of these shoes
and this is sort of my um my got some
books here I got some of the
collectibles
Podcast puffs signed by Allen Iverson my
buddy Tanner Fox's
Hot Wheel collection that he did with
his car and then I'm some of my things
from China and Germany and my book and
just a bunch of fun stuff okay so so
question for you your office is burning
down you could take one thing from that
shelf what are you taking with you
probably gotta go with the AI are you
some filly no I'm from Virginia my buddy
AJ he just gave me that there was a gift
okay you just love a mine yes yes if
somebody gives me as a gift and it means
a lot so I'd have to go with that you
got me you gotta get you gotta get a I
at your next event I love it
well that's it that's the advantage of
being will do it on Instagram because
you've got your phone and you can you
can show us around I like it so behind
the scenes so somehow it was so formal
and polished so listen man I'd love
watching your journey I don't know the
full backstory on it but I mean I saw
you on your Instagram account and
obviously had so much success with build
your empire and then you're off doing
interviews and meeting some of your
heroes and I think a lot of people feel
like they're too young to reach out and
to make connections into and to build a
show are you even 20 yet almost I'm 19
and so look I started my first real
company when I was 19
okay and I had all sorts of you know
limiting beliefs that I'm too young and
no one's going to talk to me and and you
know I'm selling to people who are three
times my age and have all this education
how did you get over that man how did
you I mean you started what 16 when did
you start doing these outreaches yeah
around 16 and the main sort of pivoting
point that sort of got me doing what I'm
doing so when I was fifteen I've always
played sports my entire life I played
hockey for ten years and lacrosse and
then ended up playing football and
during sophomore year high school I
actually had a very bad neck injury so I
was diagnosed with in her spine his
ligament damage and I was put into a
neck brace for almost six months due to
this football injury and it was during
those six months that I really dove into
personal development and started looking
at social media and finding different
mentors and started picking up books and
just really educating myself with the
time that I
because I couldn't put my time towards
practicing and playing football anymore
so it was more so an identity change at
the end of the day really figuring out
like hey I can't play football ever
again I was almost paralyzed I'm in this
neck brace for six months like what can
I do with my time as a 15 16 year old
kid that's super active right and it
allowed me to really go inside and think
inside of hey what do I want my next two
years looks like in high school can't
play sports anymore can't do what I
wanted to do so therefore I'd like I
just said I went to personal development
I started reading all these different
books thinking of rich had it wouldn't
friends influence people and Gary Vee
there's all these different world-class
entrepreneurs like yourself and it was
something where I just completely dove
in headfirst and I I found out about
building a personal brand and
documenting my my story and that's when
I first started just doing book reviews
on Instagram stories around snapchat and
I just sorted showcasing and documenting
my current reality it definitely set the
tone for me moving forward and one thing
led to the next and now we're hearing
him I'm super grateful for the
opportunity but it was one of those
things looking back we're in the most
negative point of my life where I
thought it everything was over and I was
depressed and angry
that's where looking back was the major
switch and that was I'm super grateful
for that and it's definitely been a
great great ride in the last couple of
years well let me take this in a couple
ways a couple different direction since
I think you can shed some light on a few
things
Instagram closing out 2019 what what are
the things that are working best for you
right now yeah Charlie Walker coming in
here yeah Instagram it's funny because I
treat Instagram more so like a business
card right it's so you can give it to
someone they can instantly look at it
and sort of make a positive or negative
judgment of you based on how you're
branding yourself and I think it's the
platform that everyone's on at lease
it's like hey what's your Instagram
right that maybe you have you have a
YouTube maybe you don't but for me when
I look at Instagram this is the platform
that I have spent the last two years on
usually just building and crafting and
funny story every single person I've had
on my podcast has came from my Instagram
DM and as some of those things we're
looking at Instagram
now I try to I try to be fluid as well
and I think there's another platform
which I'll mention here in a second that
I'm also kind of looking at tick-tock
right and it's one of those things where
I try to be current with trends that are
happening and I was at the tick-tock
headquarters in LA a couple weeks ago
and there and just the growth and what's
happening on there is insane but back to
the point of Instagram
I'm just utilizing it mainly for
connection yes I document my story yes
we post a lot of content I build your
empire but for us it comes down to like
you know we can get in touch with people
we can get in touch with people to speak
at our events to be in our podcast and
it's a phenomenal way to network like
we're doing right now right we're on
this year I'm live we're connecting
we're touching base we this is how we
got in touch to do my interview on my
podcast and for me it's been a it's been
a blessing to just in something that's
so many doors to connect with people and
that's my core intent when I'm using
Instagram it's not get the most likes
not to get the most followers or videos
yes I believe that's important in terms
of audience and your reach but the core
intent for me is connecting with the
right people to then have on my podcast
and speak in my events so that I can
truly build a relationship with them
long term and getting a different
business opportunities and is that
what's the difference for you between
Casey Adams and Instagram because you've
got your own count that you see now
versus build your empire yeah so build
your empire - all right now it's one of
those things where relaunching a whole
new content strategy and I'm by the way
here's phenomenal just went out there
and up but they'll jump off I think it's
a little different because we want to
make sure the platform we have in terms
of the motivating and inspiring
entrepreneurs from all over the world we
want to make sure that were we're
posting three times a day very
consistent on point with the branding
strategy
we're not my personal it's maybe I'll
post four times a week or three times a
week it's more personal I'm posting
pictures of me or the people on with or
the interviews that I'm doing so build
ramparts mainly based on the content
around inspiration motivations from
higher sources more so going with the
theme build your empire and then like I
said for me it's just documenting the
interviews and I'm doing the stories
that I'm telling and it's I would say
that's the major difference so on the on
the Builder Empire side what change are
you making or what do you really feel
Ksenia on for the next three months on
instagram yeah I would say it would
build your empire I definitely want to
start going live more on there because
whenever I we did go live on there me or
my partners if we would always have
phenomenal feedback and it's something
we haven't done in a in about two months
or so and I believe it's just we haven't
really been dialed in with it so I would
say moving in the next three months
we've already had this brief
conversation - and we haven't we have an
execute on it yet but I'm definitely
going more live on build your empire
doing little things like this this is
something I personally like to do and
bring on different people and I think
that's definitely something we're
definitely gonna be focusing on is just
making the human interaction you know
showing the office showing the the room
being personable because that all people
like to hear and see cool all right
sneak peek of what's to come looking
forward to it
if I see you online I'll I'll try to I'd
pop in and say hi for sure so talk
tick-tock what are you doing there man
yes it's funny and um nobody eats at me
actually as well but tick tock it's one
of those things where I personally
completely disregarded it for the past
eight months it's been like they
rebranded and I think it's bite media
acquired musically they rebranded this
tick tock a year ago so there's like
this one year of tick tock just going
viral and I completely was disregarding
it until like two months ago where me my
buddy Sean and Karen we're looking at
tick tocking like we just see everything
going viral so many different challenges
and from an attention perspective of
like hey there's a lot of consumers on
there that are going crazy getting so
much attention - were like hey let's
just start posting a lot of content and
I literally had zero followers I post a
couple different types of videos me
doing random stuff anything from
basketball to entrepreneurship so travel
videos test with the platform and one of
my videos it had now has a little over a
hundred thousand views and I had zero
followers and then someone like Sean he
has leaves of 10 20 30 thousand views
and karen has done with millions of
views and it's just from zero followers
so it really caught our attention and
there's so many people just already
engaging so I DM at tick tock on
Instagram I email to them and long story
short I said about meeting with their
and at the corporate office in LA when I
was out there about two weeks ago and I
went to their office and they literally
were breaking it down and there's such a
new platform and they have so much
coming out with that's it's like live
streaming the advertising platform like
so many different companies as well I
was able to connect different companies
with their advertising department
because they don't really have a massive
lucrative advertising platform right now
and it's one of those things where we
were chatting with them and it's it's a
super new and intriguing I don't wanna
say I'm the tick-tock expert I mean I
just don't know that maybe have a
thousand fifteen hundred followers on it
but it's definitely something I believe
posting the content that you're already
posting on Instagram or YouTube but in a
shorter format on tick-tock is very
valuable there's there's a lot of
different artists on there like
marshmallow or sweetly from race memory
and all these different people that are
just getting on there now with there are
five hundred thousand followers but
they're posting a couple pieces of
content and this is growing massive
audiences and I think the same will work
and should work for people in the
Entrepreneurship space or music or
whatever it is and yeah there's just
super new and they're very if you if you
have a connection with their team they
can really help you craft your content
and get it out there and it's it's just
a massive market that's growing over
five hundred million monthly active
users only twenty six million are in the
u.s. so that's mainly in China and all
over a different parts of the world so
it's definitely growing a lot here in
the US and it's definitely super cool to
see if I was to make one tik-tok video
what do you think I should do basketball
I don't have a shot I mean personally I
think it would be super cool just um
because here's an idea I tried to like
make and create all this like like
in-depth content on tick-tock because
they have like very cool features or
edits or all these different things and
I try to do all this stuff to make these
videos cool but the one that went viral
or got 100,000 views was just a cool
edited video that I did nothing -
meaning I just posted it straight up so
me I think and that's happened for me
that's happened for a couple other
people I know so I would say simplicity
is key but making it relatable right so
when I when I posted my video it was
about my trip to China it was it was
cool it showed my journey it was like
taking them to the process and I don't
know I think for you
maybe something to just showcase like
what you built but in a funny way but
just testing with the different types of
entrepreneurial content right here
you're doing all these things on YouTube
that are super serious but then also
doing like the funny cool stuff I think
I think that would be a cool play all
right I'm not a really funny guy so I
got to see cool well well thank you for
putting on my radar I love how you're
branching out now and you doing events
and you're really in the street where
and promoting artists it's something I
connect with I want to help promote more
artists I own a dance studio here in
Toronto so Marcus salsa dancing school
maybe North America but for sure in
Canada and I think artists you know are
typically really poor entrepreneurs and
and I want to do a better job of trying
to showcase them and give them a
platform talk me about your evolution
into events now from going from just an
Instagram account but then you've got to
meet a lot of your heroes and do all
these interviews horizon a young but now
you're launching you've done your first
couple events you're doing some more
tell me about that evolution yeah so
it's funny because my core Intel was
social as always like you stands up to
me to meet my heroes and meet people
that I connect with and have my podcast
but one of the things that I'm one time
I said I'm Tai Lopez's house and he told
me you can go to business events or you
can host them but if you do both your
network will expand really quickly and
in late 2017 that's when I really I had
my first event in San Diego California
and it was with me and my buddy cheering
we we had this is this networking of
that with we had a couple you are
friends that are youtubers come out and
we sold tickets like 40 bucks just to
cover the expenses of the food and all
the different stuff we needed to get to
make it like like a good environment and
150 people ended up showing up right oh
cool
this was great let's do it Elaine I'm 17
at the time he's 18 we do it in LA it's
one of the most challenging things was
getting an Airbnb at 17 and in Los
Angeles the throws event it was
challenging but we did it in Long for
sure the next one had 250 people there
and these are just like network
these are looks like structure type of
events that we'll get into which we have
now but I had this sort of Epiphany of
pay like I'm putting on these events
I'm meeting so many cool people and it's
one of those things where I loved and I
kind of fell in love with like curating
these environments bringing cool people
together I like it when I when I can
connect somebody with someone that I
know and then they ended up having a
great relationship like that that makes
me feel good right so for me nowadays we
just did an event with builder Empire
young and reckless so CEO young and
reckless is drama Chris drama pfaff he
was on the MTV show Robin big and Rob
Dyrdek's Fantasy Factory and he comes in
the world of MTV and yes he has a
podcast but um I invited him to speak at
my our own builder Empire that in
Phoenix Arizona and the way I got in
touch with him was I had him on the
podcast so we had some rapport there
sort of like how we know he said that
right just we know social we've I've had
you on the podcast and Enola hey drama
we'd love to have you come out and speak
in my event first time we couldn't make
it second time you came out in January
long story short we had on the build
Empire House in our Paradise Valley
Arizona so drama and a bunch of cool
people in street where like D Murphy and
marking coal form iconic shout out to
iconic right there but um they all came
out smoky the event it was a phenomenal
thing maybe to like 300 people were
there and then two weeks later and this
will kind of make this sort of make
sense JAMA text me he's like hey man I
love the vibe that you are member you
were creating you know there's an 18
year old that's taken notes with a pen
and paper that's wearing Easy's that's
rockin supreme like that's his
demographic of street wear and young
entrepreneurs and people that are buying
on the reckless clothing and so he saw
that music hey like I'd love to do an
event with you so back in May May 18th
young and reckless build Empire we did a
collaboration event in Los Angeles and
we had people like Robert Green there or
and Paul Rodriguez from X Games he's won
a bunch of gold medals and we had this
like unique demographic you know someone
from Robert green to X Games gold
medalist to someone like drama or Mikey
Taylor who's also a skateboarder to my
buddy chase euro who's massive and
e-commerce basically it was all these
different topics but our our main goal
of it was to bridge the gap between the
culture and fashion and street wear but
Bridget to entrepreneurship
actually bring value and go into
business development and have these
entrepreneurs actually give you tactical
advice that make it cool make it fun now
if we like this we like to sort of call
it like bridging complex con with the
everyday business event where you're
actually sitting down and taking notes
and that's that's sort of our goal with
it is to make an experience where you
can walk in and it's just it's it's a
cool and feel-good vibe you know set up
you walk in suit and tides we want to
make it very cool and engaging and
that's our goal so are we're doing
another one October 12th in LA and we
have people like Rob here that come to
speak and Michael mente who's the
founder of revolve they're a public
company and our hope those are some more
so bring in people that you don't hear
from often because um yeah I'm sure you
know there's a lot of events where you
hear the same stuff or it's regurgitated
so our goal is to really bring in
high-level people that you may not hear
from a lot and with dramas connections
and some of mine them we're gonna we're
gonna do that so I'm super excited I'll
just check my schedule I'm in LA on the
14th
okay got it just missed it there I was
like an October 12 I'm close I'm close I
know I'm close so they weren't there yet
um I won't repeat summit okay and then
meeting gaybraham and a bunch of people
out in LA this event that you know I'm
super curious because again I wanna I
want to be able to help more artists is
it is it a speaking gig look at people
coming up and sharing their ideas is it
just hey let's hang out and have drinks
well it definitely is definitely
speaking involved so we have keynotes
and panels and you also do like Q&A
interviews so last time we had like
drama has a podcast guard group tower
him and his two business partners Dee
and Anand they'll do like a an hour chat
about current topics culture what's
happening like current trends and
they'll do like a live podcast but
mainly for this one is just going to be
Q&A like drama and rob dyrdek they'll do
a Q&A I'll do an interview with Michael
mente and it's really something where
it's not just like us speaking with the
guests but we make it a very open Q&A so
if someone the audience has a question
we want to make sure we get to them and
it's definitely one of those things
that's we don't want to make it so it's
no one can raise their hand or a
communicator speak up and that's
something
we really encourage people to do their
we make people aware of it but um yeah
it's definitely speaking oriented and
it's it's gonna be it's a seven-hour
event so from 9:00 yeah 10:00 to 5:00
super quick easy fast but um straight to
the point it's back to back to back the
speaker is enough yeah it's it's three
keynotes and then three channels that's
sick dude so but this is not an Airbnb
where are you hosting this yeah so this
is our exact candela LaBrea it's a super
cool venue it's it's like Google's had
events there SpaceX has had events there
it's a super cool vibe super cool wood
floors stage like an upstairs VIP lounge
sort of thing and um super cool cool
spot right on libera Avenue right in
Hollywood so I'm it's super cool spot
but that wasn't pictures but so you got
a bang you didn't have how many people
how many people this is me five hundred
five hundred people say this is a legit
like big event
there goes you go from five hundred to a
thousand and fifteen hundred and lost or
shorts sellout Staples Center in four
years that's the goal and how off me
doing these so these ones will be
unrecognizable Empire and reckless twice
a year the bigger ones and probably
start doing like these mini satellite
events where we have 50% hundred person
pop-up sort of thing but it's younger
breakfast twice a year and then build
your empire we've done about seven this
year we were in Germany we're gonna be
in Puerto Rico and we did one in LA done
a couple in Phoenix that's where I'm
based out of but um those are the
smaller 150 250 person meetups Q&A
panels as well but okay not in like a
massive venue with 500 plus people this
is definitely one of the bigger ones so
you go to Germany yes yup and so and
then what you partner with a local
youtuber or artist and say let's put on
an event together and I was walking by
works yes the mighty partners they had a
good friend in Germany Brighton
Frankford that there's a lot of
different events where he just is he has
a bunch of free events couple hundred
people will come out and we've decided
to partner up with him and actually sell
tickets to it and we had about 400
people in Germany and I saw people it
was one of the whole
because no one like no one 80% of the
room did not speak English well and that
we had to put these translators in our
ears and they did as well so instead of
me talking like I normally talk I had to
slow it down and be very meticulous
because as I was speaking there was
translators in the back which I'm sure
you've seen and they're in there
translating me to German so that people
can understand it but I mean it was very
cool it was it was a different obviously
allows my first time in Europe and we
went out there had a great time and it's
definitely something that from an
international perspective kind of gave
me a new perspective in terms of like
the the audience in these different
parts of the world and you want to do an
event in Australia and we're doing one
in Puerto Rico in November so it's
definitely something we want to start
doing these little satellite events and
partnering with different people in
different countries that have an
audience that can put people in rooms
and obviously we do our part to see it
where our audience can get out there or
if you have an audience out there to
come support it but that's definitely
something we we plan to do more and more
of it it was super fun in a great time
in Frankfurt when I was 22 I went to
Brunei that the royal family flew me out
to speak to their group it was a two-day
event and they're trying to get off of
oil so they want to they want to promote
entrepreneurship so they had me come in
talk with entrepreneurship I was
speaking for two days and after the
first day they said man Evan we love you
but nobody in the room when they're
stains you because you're speaking so
quickly especially when you get
energized and excited you'll even go
faster but they like they too I said
okay I'm gonna slow this right down
because because it is ESL or or they
have the the translators and yeah do
them super calm I'm so like I gotta see
if I can change my flight legit I really
want to get into helping people in the
arts community more walk me through the
stuff I'm just super curious
walk me through you got seven hours so
this is October 12th right yep
seven hours from what 10:00 to 5:00 you
said yep 10:00 to 5:00 what happens like
hour by hour is it all in one room yes
scheduled on yesterday so it's one of
those things where yeah I'm a member so
to start off the day I'm not sure do you
know who I'm Ryan Blair is Ryan Blair
sounds familiar
Ryan blank he was in network marketing
Sally's yeah hit by Sally's it was a
marketing company and then he's he was
drawing Adams early mentors and not too
much but I'm gonna be he's gonna be one
of the first QA that we're doing and
then people that we have locked in that
I can publicly say Rob Dyrdek who I'm
sure maybe some people know of Rob
Dyrdek was the guy behind Rob Fantasy
Factory and Robin big different brands
so he's gonna be one of our keynote
speakers Michael mente who I said
founder of revolve which is a public
company and rice Sutton's the the
branding partner at revolve they're
gonna be there talking about fashion
because they've literally bootstrap the
whole startup did over almost half a
billion dollars and then just took their
company public so taking like that
interview and sitting down with them for
an hour we want to make sure that's
something very important and people
really understand and I'm super excited
about that as just a consumer as well
and I'm sure the audience will love be
as well and so is it seven hours and
seven different either Q&A or podcasts
with influential people in the industry
yep yep so yeah actually I just
scheduled just pulled up so it's going
to be 45 minutes Tina at the start then
a 30 minute Q&A then another 30 minute
Q&A and then a panel so it seems like
one person than a two-person queue a
two-person Q&A panel then an hour hour
and a half lunch break and then just
right back to it so it's gonna be just
super back-to-back and we have someone
like I'm not mastered you know who
Trevor Mowatt is know so yeah he's
business partners with Russell Wilson
and I'm he's like his brain trainer he
was ranked in Sports Illustrated like
the top brain trainer of the end of
Sally there's a lot of stuff with
different teams and he's a super low-key
guy maybe has like four thousand
followers on Instagram but he's starting
to put out more and more content but we
have him gonna be there and he's he's
just a very high level performer that um
like I said he doesn't really do too
much different speaking events so our
whole goal is to bring in these these
different names that you may not hear
from that often in and bring them in
cool vibe together very conversational
and nothing to corporate structure and
shooting type mentality but hey yeah
it's a strictly related control right
young and reckless is streetwear
oriented their average demographic is 18
to 25 and our biggest point - and this
is I want to make sure I say this is our
last event we really only flip tickets
for 50 bucks and this time it's gonna be
a hundred dollars and it's something
where yes we I've had and I've been to
all these different events where there's
five grand 2,500 bucks 1,000 bucks and
we've had events like that but our whole
goal with these events young and
reckless village Empire is to make it
accessible and to fail with people and
do create a bigger community so it
literally tickets are 100 bucks and you
get access to the entire day and it's
gonna be one of those things where the
speakers will be walking around the
floor you can actually meet them in it
it really comes down to someone that's
maybe me at 16 years old to walk up to
someone and actually introduce yourself
and figure out where there's value there
and that's why I personally love doing
this and at a low ticket cost like that
it's very accessible to a lot of people
and we want to make sure that we make it
like that so that everyone can be
involved especially if you're 16 18 or
20 and just getting started that's
that's sort of our goal you're killing
me man you're killing me I can't believe
I'm there two days later I'm gonna look
at my schedule yeah man okay for
everybody else who is interesting where
do they go where are they going build
your empire back where they going yeah
we're launching tickets on next Tuesday
and that's going to be launching so when
you do is this going to be on young and
reckless calm and if you can it'll be
slash Bill's Empire or slash tickets
there's nothing formalized yet but if
you follow build Ram pyar or myself or
drama or gun and reckless we will be
blasting it out on there Tuesday and um
we could sell out within two weeks and
last time we saw it out and we don't
open any more tickets so it's gonna be a
good one where are you Casey Adams gonna
be posting it so I'll be posting it on
my personal page just at Casey Adams one
on Instagram and I'll be I'll be talking
about it giving a whole speaker line up
the entire in depth detail and are you
gonna do ossama just
oh dude I've seen your feet like a man
oh it's killing me or anything I got on
Bali anyway dude I mean I appreciate
your time it's been awesome to see your
journey I know I reached out to you
because I saw your kicks
man I love what Casey's up to and it's I
didn't know you've been doing events for
that long I thought this was a newer
thing for you so but that's awesome to
see that yeah definitely wanted to love
to see how we can get you involved as we
as we move forward cause it's that bit
something that I plan to do like for the
rest of my life just because I love
putting on events and bring good people
together and um yeah you're someone I'd
love to build with and um yeah
definitely let's definitely stay in
touch because I know I love doing I'll
have to invite you on what if our life
seems I've build rep let's go yeah I'm
down dude preciate you man thank you
take care okay so two quick updates one
I was able to change my schedule around
that changed my flight so that I could
be at that event in LA if you want to
join I mean you want to be there's a
link in description go check it out come
say hi take some pictures sign some
books ask me questions super pumped to
meet you and to if you want to see the
interview I did with Tom bill you check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there